I love this movie yeah this movie's
another level it's I and I don't know
you've obviously seen it yeah it was
like for me the fastest two and a half
hour movie I've seen in a long time I
agree I've watched 90 minute films that
have felt longer than this oh 100 yeah
so you've been involved in the mission
franchise since mi3 you have witnessed
Tom do ridiculous stunts that have to
have scared you as a friend when you
think from mission three to this one and
you think about all the major set pieces
he's done rank the the Simon Pegg
nervousness on the stunts in terms of
you sitting there watching or not
wanting to watch like which the set
pieces and then how nervous you were and
maybe some sort of ranking system the
ones that I've been present for like
literally on the day so I'm I'm there
while it's happening I would say number
one would be the cliff jump just because
you know the the Gap that would occur
between when he disappeared to this to
the radio saying good canopy which is
when we know he deployed his parachute
that that space was like an eternity we
just it would be silence and we'd all be
that everybody was up there me Palm
Tarzan Haley is we're all up there and
we're just waiting for that good canopy
and we'd all just relax and it was it
was genuinely terrifying second one I
would say is probably the airplane
hanging onto the airplane in Rogue
Nation I was there sort of like
um on the ground in my ghillie suit kind
of watching that happen and that was
just you know I mean there were more
variables involved in that one than some
of the other stunts that we've done
um although actually I might I might
push that down to three because when we
were doing Fallout and he was hanging
from the helicopter Rebecca and I are on
the ground watching and no one told us
that he was going to drop from the the
skids to the to the bundle and so for
two seconds we just thought our Tom's
Fallen as he went
and then it was like no no it's part of
the thing so that was that was super
terrifying
and then I guess the LA what else did I
have I been there for the Burj Khalifa
but I would put that last only because
Tom clearly was having the time of his
life he was just spider-maning all over
the front of that building with a big
shit-eating grin on his face like I'm
having the time in my life and I
remember like peeking out the window
however many miles we were up and he was
just he was clearly very relaxed in that
one this is gonna I want to word this
right
um like he really is all kidding aside
risking his life yeah and you're
literally I mean you're his friend and
have you ever like pulled like before
stunts or just talk to him and be like
hey you know just in case you know I
love you like that kind of a thing or is
it sort of an Unwritten rule on set that
no one says things like that no I think
you're right I think that kind of thing
he we all understand it I mean Tom the
thing about Tom is that he feels an
obligation to the audience to kind of
provide this kind of thrill he
understands the value of a kind of
authentic physical uh stunt you know
practical stunt
um so we all know there's always a quiet
sense of industry on the set when we're
prepping but when we're in New Zealand
shooting Fallout and we Rebecca and I
were going home Tom was and Henry were
staying behind to do the helicopter
chase
when we said goodbye there was a slight
sense of like okay well maybe see you in
London it was hard not to kind of be a
bit like they were that there were extra
squeezes with the hugs it was a bit like
I don't know but obviously it was all
fine I had a long chat with McHugh this
morning and he said that the biggest
stunt that it's ever been done is later
this year yes
um all right do you get to be involved
in that stunt well let's see if I
survive until the end of this
installment shall we
okay I'll leave that there one of the
things though I think is really Tom and
McHugh work in an interesting way
because he was telling me he was telling
me that like the train sequence he
always knew was going to be in the third
act but he didn't understand how it was
all going to go and that they reshot it
multiple times so what is it actually
like with making a movie like this where
McHugh might just say yeah that didn't
work we're gonna redo this whole thing I
always say oddly you know when I my my
description of McCue's filmmaking style
is like in Wallace and Gromit when Grom
is laying the track in front of the
train as it's going that's kind of how
we work you know and McHugh just trusts
himself and and we all trust him that
he's never going to run out of track you
know and he'll always
you ask him a question all right what
happens in this or why are we here and
he'll say I don't know yet and you have
to trust that he is going to figure it
out because his skill his superpower as
a filmmaker and a writer is to problem
solve so you give him a broken script
and he'll fix it just like that and he's
kind of learned him and Tom have learned
to make films in such a way where they
have the big beats very very you know uh
studiously planned out but the
connective tissue the the stuff that for
the reasons for these things happening
they kind of grow as we go uh it's it's
exhilarating frustrating sometimes but
they always come up with the goods you
have to agree that it's very few
filmmakers who can do what they do in
terms of not have it all figured out
before they stand on set none I don't
think I don't think there is anyone else
that could do that you know and and Tom
and McHugh just have such a rhythm now
they've galvanized their relationships
since the Q came on board goes protocol
as a writer to now three films in his
writer director and and star they have a
relationship which is symbiotic it's
quite amazing so when McHugh first told
you that this basically AI was going to
be the thing it was many years ago and
he couldn't have known how much AI was
going to be in the media and everyone
talking about it when the movie was
coming out yeah so is he Nostradamus and
a and b
um talk a little bit about how it's it's
a great villain for the time we've
spoken about this because when McHugh
pitched the idea to me back in 2019 it
felt to me oh this is so Mission
Impossible it's kind of like it's
futuristic but it's still very much in
the kind of tech theme that mission
impossible has it's the perfect
antagonist for this series and as we've
been making the film this kind of debate
this this subject has become very much
at the Forefront of kind of the cultural
subconscious it's amazing how prescient
this film feels I think it's um it's
intriguing we've always been scared of
things that we feel might supplant us
whether it's monsters or gods or aliens
or robots this is a particularly kind of
topical uh idea because it's something
that feels more likely than any of those
other things you know and as we discuss
it and talk about the ethics of it you
know this film I think feels like a
timely warning about you know what could
happen on that note I gotta go I'm just
gonna say I can't wait to see it again
thank you buddy